previously on TV since my cholesterol is
high enough don't bother my ass tanzic
just get smarter I like simple places
like butter in my ass lollipops in my
mouth
[Music]
I took a lot of crap for sending these
opening credits for being too long the
first time we did thrown spin shirt the
beautiful ever changing scenery over the
glorious theme is a thing of wonder but
it's also almost two minutes long hands
are tied here a man who passes the
sentence must swing the Sin Lannisters
then act like fools have you watched the
previous six episodes sorry um so
because I also charles dance has
definitely had a career but he's so
awesome and the fact that he's not a
household name is a hundred percent of
sent between thailand gutting this poor
animal limehouse poetically carving up
meat on justified and Hannibal Lecter so
eloquently preparing his man meat on
Hannibal all while delivering prose this
decade created its own form of
villainous culinary exposition and it's
gross in every scenario so Cindy I shall
you spend too much time worrying about
what other people think of you well
since he's [ __ ] his sister maybe he
should your mother's dead before long
I'll be dead and you and your brother
and your sister and all of our children
and knowing this show that may just be
in the next 15 minutes you could
establish a dynasty that will last a
thousand years
dynasty actually I'm having a
premonition that with the way you meet
your end maybe you should have just
pronounce it dynastic I need you to
become the man you were always meant to
be well next year not tomorrow
seriously the way the show builds
characters relationships motives and
dynamics is otherworldly in just four
minutes we completely understand this
father-son dynamic in both the words and
the grotesque yet symbolic skinning of
the animal as it set up with us in Jamie
and I are more than brother and sister
we shared a room came into this world
together we belong together
oh and that night he called on top of me
stinking of wine and did what he did
what little he could do and he did what
he did what little he could do we wrote
this dr. George RR Seuss when the King
returns from his hunt I'll tell him the
truth you must be gone by then you and
your children I will not have that blood
on my hands
finally a show that understands that
real integrity and heroism can be
stronger than an antihero I can't wait
to see how Ned rises to King and rules
with justice and compassion I've met
many mistakes in my life national
treasure
Roman don't say a word Yale the hitter
when you play the game of Thrones you
win you die
holy dragon it's the rare show an
episode titled back-to-back double role
commercials roll all the commercials no
no no no do you have any idea how
ridiculous
she sounds throw-ins still forcing in
the unnecessary training the prostitutes
how to have fake orgasms for a full
three minutes scene because you can't
spell Game of Thrones without a little
TNA well I mean you could but it would
be pronounced Kamini of herodes well no
one wants that and only by admitting
what we are can we get what we want
nice try squeezing some character work
into this softcore throne ography but
there is no way Littlefinger would be
spilling all this to his employees in
civilized lands you refer to your
betters by their proper titles what's
that Lord why discount somewhere it
would be excellent at TV since you're
from south of the wall
that makes you a southerner to me walls
a tale is all this time do you want to
lose that chain fifty Shades of Grey joy
why would they have any opening like
this at the top of the wall they could
at least put up whatever the equivalent
of a guardrail would have been seems
like you're just asking to lose at least
a few soldiers a year to fall into their
death Jack Gleeson has some great
moments on this show his attempt to show
grief in this scene well it's not one of
them you don't want to see this I like
this Jeffery kid can't wait to see him
mature and heard Ned's guidance and
bring honor and redemption to his family
that's gonna be such a heartwarming tale
and then of Robert Baratheon I get this
isn't exactly a democratic nation but I
would think having one or two witnesses
here would be required for at the very
least
smart who gave the King this wide his
squire from the Kings own skin
this Squire Lannister boy dunt dunt da
net already knows what the Lannisters
are up to not sure why this plot
development needs to be treated as such
a surprise or even mentioned so
harvested by Kousaka maybe but what
about sea horses couldn't arrive one of
those I said too much having a few
dragons makes things easier fire
shadowing a royal pardon you can go home
now good for Jorah but seriously there
has to be a better way of communication
in these lands what if Jorah had decided
not to come to the market today or
fallen ill was this kid just pulling a
Counting Crows and hanging around until
George showed up my lady you are from
Westeros and isn't it good that she was
and also happens to be walking past and
it's also interested in your wine
considering your home poisoning plan
depends on all of us convenience
convenience
scorpion sting you came alone in Chains
without friends is this supposed to be a
motivation speech or a death sentence
you're allowed to look happy
Green they don't call him Kip happy face
Harrington for nothing going on with the
back of this guy's cloak does he have a
tail is he a dragon having no resolution
to this might be the episode's biggest
sin of all do any of you still keep the
old gods I do
just snow them no one else in this
entire group has the same religion well
that's certainly convenient for
expedited storytelling you report to
one-eyed Joe in the stables the locals
call him cotton eyed Joe so be ready for
lots of dancin and a strange penchant
for showing up at wedding receptions I
was singing for a high Lord at acorn
hall when you put his hand on my leg and
he wanted to see mother apparently this
is what happens when you serve at House
of car garyun you suggest is treason
only if we lose the political process I
am The Watcher on the walls I am the
shield that guards why do the stewards
have to take these vowels their
glorified hotel maid's may be Holiday
Inn has stricter hiring standards than I
realized
Oh Marvel DC crossover event nice for
some of us and ultra now this is a pep
talk they should seriously think about
hiring Kyle for the Nights Watch
speeches bend the knee my lord bend the
knee and swear loyalty to my son
pretty sure Jamie made sure he couldn't
bend the knee so this seems like a
lose-lose situation in more ways than
one I just warned you not to trust me I
don't trust you and you're saying not to
trust you sure then trust you
but then when I trust you and you say
not to trust you I think that means
don't trust you but then if I don't
screw it I think about this too long I'm
gonna lose my head over it
watch me
I'll do the fingering no three 6180 if I
did a 360 I'd go completely around and
end up back where I started
I'll have what she's having
you're a very lucky girl you know that
you've got to ask yourself one question
do I feel like it well do you bunker tis
but a scratch I've had worse listen to
come aboard
my lady